[Musica]
Pronto
e Davide e non posso adesso sto al Ted
ma adesso me lo devi dire Ah ho capito
Ho capito ristorantino romantico
ostriche afrodisiache champagnino Ma tu
sei una vecchia volpe Ah le hai chiesto
di sposarti e lei
grandissimo o dobbiamo andare a
festeggiare allora
questa telefonata
non è
mai avvenuta
e non è mai avvenuta perché Davide
ha avuto un cancro
e
non ha fatto in tempo a
ad andare in quel ristorante a ordinare
quelle ostriche
e a fare quella proposta
Davide era un mio amico e questo è il
mio tributo per lui
ma
Io sono sicuro che all'interno di questa
sala
in molti di noi
hanno avuto la percezione che il cancro
sia un fenomeno pervasivo sia
estremamente diffuso
E infatti il cancro interessa una
persona su due
è un numero enorme questo però allo
stesso tempo l'essere umano ha
sviluppato una strategia incredibilmente
potente per difendersi da questa
malattia e questa strategia si chiama
prevenzione pensate che con la
prevenzione Noi siamo in grado di
ridurre il numero di tumori del 50 per
cento a un numero enorme anche questo e
per capire meglio quello di cui sto
parlando proviamo a fare mente locale a
pensare a tutte le persone che
conosciamo che hanno avuto una diagnosi
di tumore Ecco Adesso proviamo a pensare
che metà di queste persone non abbiano
mai avuto un tumore
provate a pensare quanto diverse
sarebbero potute essere le loro
traiettorie di vita Ecco questo è il
potere della prevenzione
Ma allora dobbiamo chiederci Come
facciamo a prevenire i tumori e per
rispondere a questa domanda dobbiamo
farcene un'altra e Cioè dobbiamo
chiederci Perché nasce un tumore ora
tutti sappiamo che i cani sono questa
proliferazione incontrollata di cellule
Ma perché nasce per rispondere
utilizziamo la formula del cancro la
formula del cancro è una cosa molto
semplice che ci dice che la probabilità
di sviluppare un cancro dipende da due
semplici variabili la prima variabile è
il DNA quel pacchetto di istruzioni che
è presente all'interno di tutte le
nostre cellule che reditiamo per metà
dal papà per metà della mamma il DNA non
lo possiamo cambiare e può predisporci o
proteggerci dallo sviluppo di Tumori è
vero che non lo possiamo cambiare però
lo possiamo conoscere
e conoscendolo possiamo creare dei
percorsi di prevenzione Questo è quello
che faccio nel mio ambulatorio di
prevenzione oncologica ma il DNA è una
parte del discorso l'altra parte invece
è l'ambiente
l'ambiente è tutto quello che ci
circonda ed è costituito da fattori che
sono modificabili e fattori che non sono
modificabili banalmente se c'è
dell'inquinamento nell'aria noi non
possiamo farci nulla Non è che possiamo
metterci a soffiare nel cielo Sperando
che le nuvole di smog scompaiano non lo
possiamo fare però possiamo decidere
quanta attività fisica fare possiamo
decidere se fumare oppure no possiamo
decidere come mangiare se bere alcolici
Allora io oggi non vorrei parlarvi di
quelle che sono le buone abitudini per
prevenire i tumori perché le conosciamo
tutti vorrei invece parlarvi di un
qualcosa di più nascosto
diabolico anche e che ha la
caratteristica di accomunare tutte
queste buone abitudini ma soprattutto ha
il potere di renderle realizzabili
e quello cui mi sto riferendo è
l'edonismo il piacere che è questo fuoco
che ci avvicina in modo magnetico
rispetto a quello che ci piace e ci
allontana invece in modo brusco
propulsivo rispetto a quello che noi
avvertiamo come negativo ora per capire
meglio questa storia
vorrei raccontarvi la storia di un mio
paziente di cui ovviamente cambierò il
nome e i connotati in modo che sia
riconoscibile ma che realmente avvenuta
e che mi ha insegnato tantissimo e la
storia di Luca che è un ragazzo di 22
anni frequenta l'università passa un
sacco di tempo davanti allo smartphone
al computer perché deve studiare ma
anche perché gli piace Diciamoci la
verità un giorno deve andare dal suo
medico di famiglia per fare una classica
visita il medico fa la sua visita alla
sua prescrizione Poi vede lui che dice
Luca ma ti vedo un po' appesantito è
meglio che ti rimetti in forma e per
cercare di motivarlo quel medico dice Ma
lo sai che chi ha un peso corporeo
superiore alla norma ha un rischio di
morte aumentata del 30%
Vabbè rientra a casa un po' pensieroso
neanche troppo convinto Vabbè però mi sa
che devo fare qualcosa andrò a correre e
così entra a casa si mette a cercare nel
ripostiglio e lì che Fuga trova delle
scarpe tutte impolverate perché sono
anni che non le usa e forse non l'ha mai
usate Però quel giorno se le mette ai
piedi esce e va a correre e mentre lì
che sgambetta e corre su da quel fiatone
dopo 5 minuti non sta pensando Sì che
bello sto riducendo il rischio di morte
prematura del 30%. No no Ha due parole
che gli frullano per la mente e sono Che
palle
E così sarà che ci crede poco sarà che è
poco allenato sarà che non gli interessa
nulla dopo poco rientra a caso arriva il
pomeriggio dopo è il pomeriggio dopo
Luca sa che deve tornare a correre
perché il destino di una vita non si
cambia con la performance di un
pomeriggio e quindi si rimette le scarpe
sta per uscire arriva sul lato della
porta si ferma e dice
Però sai che c'è Io ho le gambe ancora
un po' indolenzite da ieri
qui mi sa che mi viene una tendinite se
vado a correre andrò domani e così
arriva domani e sta per uscire Guarda
fuori dalla finestra vedo una nuvola
leggermente scura dice
[Musica]
lì butta male prima mi sa che mi viene
un raffreddore andrò domani Insomma
l'avete capito Domani è sempre domani e
non è mai oggi e passano le settimane i
mesi e tutto cambia per non cambiare
affatto Però Luca a dir la verità ci
riserva anche delle sorprese perché sarà
che arriva la Primavera la sua anima è
più frizzante e all'università conosce
una ragazza che si chiama Chiara e se ne
innamora perdutamente solo che Chiara è
molto diversa da lui è una ragazza
atletica sportiva ha un ottimo peso
forma e Luca Un giorno chiacchiera con
lei l'università torna a casa con la
mente completamente obnubilata e
innamorato perso si mette davanti allo
specchio in uno di quei momenti di
intimità che tutti abbiamo con noi
stessi si guarda scuote la testa e dice
Ma dove voglio andare ma dove voglio
andare Guardami Guarda che sta maledetta
pancia non riuscirò mai a conquistarla
però poi ha un'idea dice però sai che
c'è mi scriverò in palestra e lo fa lo
fa davvero già quel pomeriggio si scrive
in palestra va lì certo all'inizio è un
po' imbranato un po' un pesce fuor
d'acqua Ma capita a tutti Quando andiamo
in un ambiente nuovo però non demorde
insiste va avanti migliora
progressivamente va a casa studia su
come migliorare ancora e alla fine dopo
un po' di mesi riacquisisce il suo peso
corporeo Anzi addirittura si vanta con
gli amici di avere la tartaruga ora il
senso di questa storia non è quello di
dover Aderire a degli assurdi canoni
estetici no e
non vi voglio raccontare come è finita
la storia cioè se le vite di Luca e
Chiara si siano intrecciate tra di loro
ma vi vorrei raccontare qualcosa di più
nascoste diabolico Ed è proprio il
piacere Infatti quando Luca era lì che
faceva fatica non stava pensando di
migliorare la sua salute sì magari ci
avrà anche pensato ma questo gli creava
un piacere fiacco debole inconsistente
quello che invece gli creava un piacere
acuto e bruciante era l'idea di essere
desiderato da Chiara
E allora questo per me è stato un grande
insegnamento mi ha fatto capire che
quando facciamo qualcosa perché ci fa
bene
non siamo così tanto efficaci nel
portarla a termine ma quando facciamo
qualcosa che ci piace siamo
tremendamente efficaci nel portarla a
termine
e
possiamo vedere in questo senso il
piacere come un grande fuoco No solo che
se noi lo lasciamo a se stesso questo
fuoco Mira solo realizzare se stesso e
diventa un incendio autodistruttivo Ma
se noi lo canalizziamo da un incendio
autodistruttivo diventa una fiaccola in
grado di illuminare il nostro sentiero
oscuro E allora la grossa domanda è come
facciamo a rendere queste buone
abitudini In termini di salute
realizzabili e soprattutto piene di
piacere attraverso due passi il primo è
conoscere quali sono queste buone
abitudini dobbiamo conoscerle il secondo
passo è proprio incendiarle di piacere
metterci questo fuoco dentro per esempio
non dirò devo mangiare più alimenti
vegetali non processati
no dirò sai che c'è
oggi mi creerò una ricetta perdurosa
irresistibile che mi faccia salivare
ancora prima di averla assaggiata che mi
faccia attendere con bramosia al momento
del pasto oppure non dirò devo fare più
attività fisica no dirò sai che c'è
mi scriverò un corso di ballo Sì ho
deciso Imparerò a muovermi acquisirò
delle movenze sensuali e riuscirò a
conquistare il mio stesso cuore
oppure non dirò devo smettere di fumare
no dirò
sai che c'è
pensa a Che belle esempio potrei dare i
miei figli se io dimostrassi loro che
sono in grado di smettere di fumare che
bell'esempio potrei dare loro
dimostrando che a volte la strada più
giusta è quella in salita
E allora io penso che abbiamo una grande
opportunità davanti a noi quella di
lasciar perdere le buone abitudini e
cominciare a concentrarci sul piacere un
piacere che come conseguenza ci faccia
stare bene in termini di salute Questo è
un enorme cambio di paradigma e
finalmente finalmente nella storia
dell'umanità potremmo smetterla con la
retorica del ti fa bene e cominciare
invece ad abbracciare in modo totale la
naturalezza sbalorditiva della gioia di
vivere Grazie
Grazie
[Musica]